the dramatic trial of kyle rittenhouse
is coming to a close the prosecutor made
his final arguments yesterday and as
with most of the prosecutor's tactics
these closing remarks left a lot of
people scratching their heads
so what does he do that night
oh let me tell you all the awful things
joseph rosenbaum did he tipped over a
porta potty
that had no one in it
he swung a chain
he lit a metal garbage system dumpster
on fire
oh and there's this empty wooden flatbed
trailer that they pulled out in the
middle of the road and they tipped it
over to stop some bearcats and they lit
it on fire
oh and he said some bad words he said
the n-word
is that all he did he
he just destroyed a bunch of stuff and
then set a bunch of stuff on fire and
then
tipped over a truck after he repeatedly
raped kids and threatened to kill kyle
rittenhouse and then tried to kill kyle
rittenhouse which is the very act that
prompted kyle to defend himself that's
all he did oh look what did he do what
did he do just a ton of things that led
to the very moment that justified kyle
written house shooting him
with a prosecution like this why would
written house need a defense
incredibly the arguments only got worse
from there on michael knowles as the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from robert rudehouse
who said michael jensocki's words merely
lacked economy she should have left it
at joe biden doesn't spend much time
thinking
you make a very good point i i should
have thought of this myself when jensaki
says
joe biden doesn't spend a lot of time
thinking about the let's go brandon
chance that is obviously true
because the let's go brandon chants are
one part of anything and joe biden
doesn't spend much time thinking about
anything so you're absolutely right the
prosecutor in the kyle rittenhouse case
is the charlie kelly of prosecutors it
is like the worst episode of always
sunny ever
the prosecutor the the more that his
arguments fail the more that the judge
loses patience with him the the more
desperate and outlandish he seems to get
i am waiting for this prosecutor to
bring up bird law
as one might do in an episode if it's
always sunny
one of the final
closing arguments that the prosecutor
made
is that
if you
arm yourself if you exercise your second
amendment right to keep and bear arms
you
paradoxically
lose the right to self-defense
he brought his ar-15
that's why he's got to come up with this
cockamamie theory that joseph rosenbaum
was not only going to take the gun
but take it and then turn it on the
defendant and the defendant actually
told you
that he thought joseph rosenbaum was
going to take that gun and not only kill
him but kill other people which is
really ironic considering the defendant
is the one who killed people in this
case and the only one but
putting that aside
they have to convince you that joseph
rosenbaum was going to take that gun and
use it on the defendant because they
know
you can't claim self-defense
against an unarmed man like this
you lose the right to self-defense when
you're the one who brought the gun when
you're the one creating the damn danger
so that is simply not true
that is completely that has no basis in
the law or in history or in common sense
you can't lose your right to
self-defense if you are defending
yourself if you're arming yourself to
defend yourself
then you don't have a right to
self-defense
and furthermore
if if the prosecutor's claim is that
kyle rittenhouse had no reason to
believe that the
the joseph rosenbaum this dead child
rapist he obviously wasn't dead at the
time but he was a child rapist at the
time and what he did do at the time is
threatened to kill kyle rittenhouse so
the prosecutor's saying this is a
cockamamie crazy theory that he pulled
out of thin air that he was afraid that
joseph rosenbaum was going to kill him
he literally threatened to do that he
actually said i am going to kill you
guys if i see you out tonight
and then he tried to and then he got
killed for his trouble that's what
happens that's called self-defense
then as if the prosecutor had not
embarrassed himself enough
he decided to reenact the scene he
thought okay look my my rhetorical
skills
are
pretty subpar but maybe if i pantomime
what happened if i acted out maybe then
i will be able to convince the jury that
kyle rittenhouse's obvious self-defense
was not justified so this
maniac picks up an ar-15 and just starts
swinging it around the courtroom the
defendant comes running in and drops the
fire extinguisher on the ground like
this
and then raises his left hand to the gun
and points
this is what we see in the video
him putting the fire extinguisher on the
ground and then raising the gun whoa
jon open objectives facing the wrong
direction
that's an argument okay
whoa buddy chill out
chill out with the ar-15 you lunatic
look i'm not saying that i have the most
intense rigorous firearms training that
i am some expert on guns i'm not i have
some firearms training i've fired a gun
on a number of occasions and i've
had people show me how to do it and
what's the first thing they tell you not
to do what's the very first thing
if you've ever touched a gun in your
life the first thing they tell you not
to do don't point it at people actually
there are two first things you're gonna
hear don't point it at people and don't
put your finger on the trigger unless
you are ready to kill whatever is in
front of the barrel of that gun and what
does this schmuck do he picks up a
freaking ar-15 puts his finger on the
trigger and starts swinging it around
the courtroom he should be disbarred for
this
that's not an exaggeration
if i were at a gun range if i were in a
gun store and i behaved like this i
would be kicked out of that store in two
seconds
much less a court of law
but the gun's not loaded okay first of
all
if you've been paying attention to the
news over the past few weeks you'll know
that sometimes people think guns aren't
loaded when they actually are
if the set of alec baldwin's movie had
paid a little more attention to gun
safety the cinematographer would still
be alive
but two
it just shows the
unseriousness of this prosecution
this guy
this prosecutor who's representing the
state is trying to make claims about
kyle rittenhouse's use of a gun and his
use of his right to self-defense without
knowing even the most basic things about
guns or the right to self-defense
he was wrong on the law and he's wrong
on the gun and he has absolutely no idea
what he's talking about and the only
thing that he can hope for in this case
is that
the
culture of scapegoating kyle rittenhouse
the culture of saying right wing bad
left-wing good white guy bad other all
the victims not victims all of the
people who were killed
by kyle rittenhouse and self defense in
this case we're white too so the race
isn't a huge issue here but is it a blm
protest so you know blm
rioter is good
anti-blm
protesters bad right they're just
counting on this media narrative
and the pressure of the president and
the pressure of blm and the threats that
are coming in from the left to try to
sway the jury
because on the facts of the case on the
logic of the case
the prosecution doesn't have
anything
the one charge the one charge in this
case that i thought maybe they'll get
kyle rittenhouse on or maybe they ought
to get kyle rittenhouse on
is the gun charge maybe he shouldn't
have had that gun maybe that gun wasn't
legal to have in that place or to be
held by him at that time that was one of
the charges against kyle rittenhouse and
the judge threw that one out yesterday
is the firearm here now
yes
we can either measure it
or
you can stipulate that it is it does not
meet what i've
stated are the requirements
and if it
is out of compliance
if it if it is
if the barrel length is less than 16
inches
or an overall length less than 26 inches
then
i'll deny the motion if it does not meet
those specifications then this most
defense motion will be granted
we are not disputing
that the
barrel that the barrel length is
appropriate
is it legal
it is not a short-rail shotgun or a
short barreled rifle yes
either by barrel or by overall length
correct all right and then count to
six is dismissed
there it is and then that's dismissed
and the prosecution you know tweedledee
and tweedledum sitting over there
are keep answering very reluctantly
they're answering all the judge's
questions so hold on you're telling me
the barrel length is fine uh uh
yeah yeah the barrel length is fine okay
and you're telling me the overall length
of the gun is fine uh yeah yeah that's
true so you're telling me the gun is not
an illegal gun well uh
yeah i guess all the parts of it are
legal and uh
no so yeah i guess okay no it's not
illegal it's illegal yeah okay
okay well then that dumb charge is
dismissed so the best shot you had
other than relying on
mob rule and political pressure and and
scapegoating the best legal case you had
thrown out the window
you know
speaking of windows
it's very important to get good window
treatments that is going to really
really help beautify your home which is
why i would recommend you check out
hunter douglas hunter douglas can help
you with their incredible window shade
designs gorgeous fabrics and control
systems that are so advanced they can be
scheduled to automatically adjust to
their optimal position throughout the
day
maybe it's the way the shades diffuse
harsh sunlight to cast a beautiful glow
across the room maybe it's being able to
enjoy the view outside the window while
protecting your privacy inside or maybe
it's just that goldilocks moment when
you walk into a room and everything
about it looks and feels just right i
find this especially as a conservative
myself i think aesthetics really matter
i think being in beautiful places really
matters especially with light it was one
of the main things i was focused on when
i was looking to get my house here in
tennessee
your shades can be set with hunter
douglas's power view technology they can
be set to automatically reposition for
the perfect balance of light privacy and
insulation go to hunterdouglas.com
knowles today take advantage of the
season of style rebate savings event
hunterdouglas.com knowles for limited
savings offer expires december 6 2021.
so
the
prosecution
case is failing
the jury might still convict him we
don't know but the prosecution's case
is
failing and so what can we expect
people to say good
law has been
upheld justice has been done we have
faith in our institutions we trust
the pillars of our democracy and we will
stand by no
the libs are going to riot if if he gets
off the hook
and that's what they're expecting and
that's what the democrat governor of
wisconsin is expecting the democrat
governor wisconsin tony evers has placed
500 wisconsin national guard troops on
standby in kenosha
for the expected verdict in the written
house case because he's concerned about
violence is he concerned about violence
from trump supporters no from white
supremacists who don't don't really
exist no
from
the insurrectionist
right winger no it's from the libs the
libs who torched the country and rioted
and committed murder and or and were
arsons and and started all of this
madness in the first place how did the
kyle rittenhouse case even happen the
kyle rittenhouse case happened because a
degenerate criminal named jacob blake
went into a home sexually assaulted a
woman and then drove off with a van full
of her kids and or tried to drive off in
a van full of her kids and before he
could do that he resisted arrest a bunch
of times and finally before he got in
that car with a weapon in there a cop
shot him completely justifiably and then
the libs rioted over that and the libs
rioted and attacked people and burned
down stores and burned down property and
then kyle rittenhouse went to protect
some of that and he was threatened with
murder and he fired back in self-defense
that's how we got here
you don't need to go back to ancient
history you just need to go back a few
days before the events that are in
question took place and now it looks
like we're going to get a whole repeat
it's deja vu all over again
and it's not the right-wing
insurrectionist people you know when
when the libs i guess they still say
this when they said that the january 6th
january 6th capitol hill riot when they
said that was the
worst insurrection in our country
in history or it was the worst attack in
washington since 1812 or it was whatever
they were not only wrong
they were perfectly wrong the the
capitol hill
incident was not even the worst
insurrection of the year
wasn't the worst insurrection in six
months
wasn't the deadliest wasn't the most
destructive wasn't the greatest threat
to our system of law
that insurrection was called blm that
insurrection was called antifa and that
took place for six months eight months
cities around the country
and it looks poised to take place again
the democrat governor believes that's
the case we have daily wire reporters on
the ground right now
in kenosha
because look hopefully it's totally
peaceful
but if past is precedent
it won't be
this is the reason i bring it up is not
just to harp on
the libs and point out how they're
burning the country to the ground it's
to give you a little tool here which i
suspect many of you have intuited
already which is
this is generally a way to tell who the
good guys are and who the bad guys are
if the verdict in a trial
is going to even even if it were an
unjust verdict which in this case if
written house gets off that will be a
very just verdict but even if it were
unjust
if the the verdict is going to cause one
group of people to burn things down and
kill people and and riot in the streets
that group they're probably the baddies
they're probably not the goodies they're
probably
the baddies
and
the libs who are
continue to talk about january 6th as
though it were more than just a little
blip in the news cycle compared to what
else has gone on they are either
ignorant or disingenuous
and there are a handful of so-called
republicans who are helping them out to
do that as well although i guess they
might not be republicans for long the
wyoming republican party has just voted
to kick liz cheney out of the party
they they are no longer recognizing liz
cheney as a member of the republican
party and
i
you know i hate to say i told you so i'm
not sure if i had anything to do with
this vote but the timing is a little bit
weird because because
yesterday yesterday or the day before on
this show i guess it would have been
yesterday because today's tuesday
yesterday on the show
i mentioned that liz cheney simply is
not a republican
as a practical matter she might have an
r next to her name she might even vote
with republicans on a number of issues
but as a practical matter whenever there
is a crucial vote
whenever there is an actual
fight between the democrats and the
republicans she now sides with the
democrats
and that's true in party politics it's
true in the media where does she go on
tv she goes on the left-wing news
networks
she takes orders from nancy pelosi
in the crucial presidential election she
votes for the democrat and the crucial
votes in the house she votes with the
democrats so she just is a democrat
and she's dishonest as far as democrats
go because she pretends to be a
republican and so i i said
if you were to kick liz cheney out of
the republican party it's not as though
that would be a punishment or some
acrimonious big momentous event it would
just be acknowledging reality she is not
a republican for all intents and
purposes and the wyoming gop apparently
recognizes that
and
it's
that's an important thing
not because i who cares about liz cheney
she doesn't really matter all that much
no one
no one really supports her no
republicans really support her right now
and the democrats are only pretending to
support her because she's useful to them
but the minute she's no longer useful to
them they're going to throw her to the
curb so
she she doesn't matter but the principle
matters okay
it is important for your political party
to acknowledge reality and and so in
this case they are now beginning to
acknowledge reality it's not it's not
about infighting on the republicans or
all the republicans scrapping with one
another
the girl just isn't she just isn't a
republican okay and the wyoming gop is
acknowledging that now speaking of
political infighting
there is even more delicious
political infighting going on right now
among the democrats
not just among any democrats between the
president
and the vice president
you remember that
kamala harris is very upset with joe
biden
she feels that she's being sidelined
she's not being respected she's not
being defended she's got lower approval
ratings than any vice president in
decades if not ever she's got a lower
approval rating right now than dick
cheney did in 2007 after the iraq war
and after he shot a guy in the face so
she is really
really low they were calling
dick cheney darth vader in those days
okay and she's lower than him about 27
28 percent
and so she wants political support from
joe biden joe biden
either can't give it to her he's not
capable of it or he's not willing to
give it to her so this is what cnn's
reporting
many in the vice president's circle fume
that she's not being adequately prepared
or positioned and instead is being
sidelined the vice president herself has
told several confidants she feels
constrained in what she's able to do
politically yeah duh of course you're
restrained you're the vice president
your job is to take orders from the
president biden says jump you say how
high that's your job
so what's she gonna do what is what can
kamala harris do
she's in a position where she is serving
entirely at the pleasure of the
president
she
is in a role that historically is just
not that important
she isn't particularly likable in
herself that's why she was the first
person out of the race in 2016 or 2020
rather in the democrat primary so what's
she going to do she's going to do
one of the only things she ever could do
in her political career she's going to
play the race card that's right she this
is according to the cnn reporting a
former harris staffer who spoke to
current aides and harris allies said
it's hard to miss the specific energy
that the white house brings to defend a
white man pete buttige knowing that
kamala harris spent almost a year taking
a lot of the hits that the west wing
didn't want to take themselves
now so they're willing to support p
buddha judge why is that
is it because well we'll just tell you
it's cause he's a white guy
kamala is a black hey joe
if you don't back us up joe we're gonna
call you racist it's the only thing we
can do we don't have any skills or
likability or any moves but there's one
thing we got baby
it's the color of our skin joe and we're
it's the worst thing you can be called
in america you want to be called a
racist joe but you better defend us you
better watch out
now
we can all engage in a little shot in
freudia here we can all
take a little pleasure in joe biden and
the democrats getting hoisted on their
own petard right on that they love to
play the race card they love to use
disingenuous accusations of racism
against us and against their opponents
and now it's being used against them and
that's a delicious thing but it is still
wrong it's a bad thing to have happen
and it's silly
the the premise of it is that racism
which today means basically nothing it's
been defined to me nothing at all
is the worst possible thing in the world
but there are there are worse things
right
uh genocide that would be that would be
a worse thing i guess it's related but
uh abortion that's a much worse thing
uh rape and murder those are worse
things than uh
like
there are worse things than racism and
and yet in our
shallow moral discourse these days it's
the worst thing you've got and the white
house
they got the message the white house
actually did
respond
now the white house doesn't respond to
calls for
gasoline prices to go down so we're
responding ourselves that's why you got
to check out get upside get upside that
is a command
and it is also the name of this
incredible free app right now my
listeners are making up to 25 cents for
every single gallon of gas every single
time they fill up you just download the
free get upside app in the app store or
google play right now use promo code
knowles canon wles get a bonus 25 cents
per gallon on your first fill up that is
up to 50 cents cash back do not pay full
price at the pump anymore get cash back
using get upside just download the app
for free use promo code knowles
canadawlas get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your first tank some people
who drive a lot are making as much as
two to three hundred bucks per month
there is no cash
there is no catch there is a lot of cash
the cash gets added right to your bank
account okay it's super easy you never
go straight to your bank account or if
you prefer paypal or an e-gift card for
amazon and other brands download the
free get upside app and use promo code
knowleskanerwlis
to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your first tank with code
knowles
it is no secret that the left is going
to force compliance with their radical
agenda across the board whether it's the
media lying to push their gun control
narrative over the course of the written
house trial whether it's the
government's federal government's
attempt to enforce vaccine mandates on
employers it is becoming clear that
compliance getting you to kneel to them
is the goal that's why here at the daily
wire
we're fighting every day against this
kind of tyranny from our honest coverage
of the written house trial
to the lawsuit we've taken out against
the biden administration for their
unconstitutional vaccine mandates
we're applying the pressure we're not
just fighting for our own employees
i'm glad that we're fighting for our own
employees but we're not just fighting
for them we're fighting for the freedom
of every single american who's facing
termination based on this
unconstitutional mandate
very important that everyone's voice is
allowed right now if you want to support
the fight to make your personal medical
decisions without the government having
your employers force you to take the
fouchyache sign our petition against
biden's mandate hundreds of thousands of
americans have already signed the
petition but we need many more people to
stand with us to reach our goal of one
million so please head on over to
dailywire.com
do not comply to sign the petition today
we'll be right back with a lot more
kamala harris has been whining for a
long time and her approval ratings are
plummeting
so she made one complaint that the white
house had to respond to she
threw back channels through leaks
through allies of friends of associates
said that joe biden's a racist
he defends buddha judge more than he
defends me he's a big racist
gosh sure would be a shame if the vp had
to call joe biden a racist and then all
of a sudden
the white house responds
but listen to how they respond quote
this is from jen saki white house press
secretary quote
for anyone who needs to hear it
the vice president is not only a vital
partner to the president of the united
states but a bold leader who has taken
on key important challenges facing the
country from voting rights to addressing
root causes of migration
to expanding broadband
oh
that is
oh hell hath no fury
like a press secretary who is being
who is defending her man who is who is
uh facing criticism from the vice
president
it's it sounds look this is such a
beautifully crafted tweet i i have got
to hand it to jen saki we occasionally
make fun of jen saki for not being as
good at her job as her predecessor was
but this was a really well written tweet
it kind of broadly looks like she's
defending kamala harris
but every line every syllable is
attacking kamala harris
for anyone who needs to hear it right
she's saying i don't want to send this
tweet you guys are making me send the
street i hate i'm doing it grudgingly
the vp is not only a vital partner
not a good partner
not an excellent partner not an a
wonderful good terrific good for the
country partner no vital
vital meaning
alive she's
not only does she have a pulse but she's
a bold leader again not a good leader
not an impressive leader not an
accomplished leader bold and she is bold
you're pretty bold if you're the vice
president and you're going to accuse
your boss of racism
the guy who picked you
a woman of color
of color that's right that's the magic
card and that's the only reason she was
picked joe biden actually admitted that
he said i'm going to pick a black woman
and then he had two choices it was she
he had three choices he had kamala
harris who is awful and unlikable in the
first person of the primary he had karen
bass who's literally a communist uh
congresswoman karen bass and he had
susan rice who was the fall man for
benghazi
so the latter two he couldn't pick
so he was stuck with kamala harris a
bold leader okay who has taken on key
important challenges facing the country
from voting rights voting what does that
even mean there's nothing nothing's
really a big deal with voting rights
right no one's no one's right to vote is
really threatened and in as much as the
right to vote is threatened the
democrats are losing on that right
because the the republican voter
integrity measures are going into a
place so
either a nothing burger or a failure
to addressing the root causes of
migration well we've got the worst
migration crisis possibly in our history
going on right now so that total failure
to expanding broadband that's just that
that's the twist of the knife
if
it weren't obvious before and i think it
was
joe biden and kamala harris detest one
another they don't like each other don't
forget kamala harris's high point of her
presidential campaign was when she like
this accused joe biden of being a racist
and saying that joe biden was trying to
segregate schools when she was a kid or
some kind of nonsense
right there is no love lost between
these people
but they have to stick together this is
their bed and they have made it
kamala harris knows a thing or two about
this in politics they when you make your
bed you you have to lie in it and uh and
in this case kamala harris made herself
into the token candidate from from day
one she was going to be the token
candidate i'm going to make race the
central issue of my campaign and i'm
going to accuse my strongest opponents
of racism and joe biden launched his
campaign by saying donald trump's a
racist was the first thing he said in
the campaign and i'm not going to be a
racist so he had to prove that
by picking at least a black person if
not a black woman to get even more
intersectional points and now they're
stuck together
and we get to pull out the popcorn and
enjoy the theatrics speaking of
unlikable democrats
i
can't believe that this is not a
saturday night live sketch i guess the
way i know that this is not a saturday
night live sketch is that this is funny
we have
a
twice failed
democrat from texas now announcing a
third one he ran for senate and lost
he ran for president and really lost
and now what happens when you lose twice
you run a third time for a completely
different office ladies and gentlemen i
give you
beto for governor of texas
i'm running for governor and i want to
tell you why
this past february when the electricity
grid failed and millions of our fellow
texans were without power which meant
that the lights wouldn't turn on the
heat wouldn't run and pretty soon their
pipes froze and the water stopped
flowing they were abandoned by those who
are elected to serve and look out for
them
it's a symptom of a much larger problem
that we have in texas right now those in
positions of public trust have stopped
listening to
serving and paying attention to and
trusting the people of texas and so
they're not focused on the things that
we really want them to do like making
sure that we have a functioning
electricity grid or that we're creating
the best jobs in america right here in
texas or that we have world-class
schools or that we make progress on the
things that most of us actually agree on
like expanding medicaid or legalizing
marijuana
so guys i
look bros i just i just really want to
be a politician all right i'm just gonna
put my cards on he this guy is more
matthew mcconaughey than matthew
mcconaughey you know people said matthew
mcconaughey is going to run for governor
he sort of is it's just it's like
matthew mcconaughey without the
intelligence or virtue or charisma then
you get beto o'rourke and so he's
running because he just really wants to
be a politician
and it's very easy to make fun of beto
he is probably the most easily mockable
politician
alive
i'm trying to think of one who's
someone said that beto is like the
democrat jeb not even close jeb is like
alexander the great compared to beto
o'rourke okay
jeb is charlemagne compared to beto
o'rourke
but
well we can mock him as a skateboarding
dude bro whiny millennial
kerouac reading
joke
loser
i wouldn't count him out
i i wouldn't i wouldn't i'm urging
caution do not
do not count beto out he's a joke
whose high point of his presidential
campaign was when he said hell yeah i'm
going to take your ar-15s yeah yeah man
yeah yeah wouldn't it be cool what if
the color that you see as green i see as
blue you know he's just like his lines
just come out of freshman philosophy
seminars but
persistence can pay off
okay we talked about this yesterday on
the show the power of persistence
democrats are nothing if not persistent
jon ossoff ran for congress in georgia
he was a joke he was a very silly
candidate that the democrats and
especially people in hollywood dumped
about a bazillion dollars into and then
he lost and we all laughed at him and he
even looked like beto and he kind of
talked like beto and you know what what
he is now he's senator ossoff because he
lost he loses loses loses loses until he
wins right he's just they are just
persistent
stacy abrams loses the georgia
governor's race if you asked a lot of
people in georgia right now who's the
governor they would probably tell you
stacey abrams
because she's so persistent she keeps
she tried to be vice president
i'm sure she's going to run again she's
going to run for a million other offices
until she wins
richard nixon actually he's one of ours
who did this
richard nixon would have the
presidential race stolen from him in
1960 and he keeps running runs runs runs
runs runs and then he wins
do not count out pers it's not it's not
enough for republicans to just pass the
law
get the
decision from the judge
sign the executive order and then say
we've solved it no you've got to keep up
that persistence i can't believe we have
to learn anything from beto or work but
we might and speaking of persistence
president trump president trump
is dominating the 2024 republican
presidential field a lot of us are
talking about who should the candidate
be
in 2024
a lot of people are talking up ron
desantis a lot of people would mention
ted cruz he was basically the number two
guy in 2016. a lot of people are talking
about i don't know josh hawley josh
hawley clearly wants to run a lot of
people are talking about nikki haley she
would run in the more moderate lane
probably a lot of people are talking
about i don't know christine ohm she
she's an attractive candidate she
did well during covid she would also
probably be a little bit more modern
people are talking about tim scott
people none of that matters right now
what i'm here to tell you is it doesn't
matter
what that great thing is that desantis
did in florida or what that great piece
of legislation none of the only question
that matters for the 2024 presidential
race is will trump run or will he not
run
because if he runs
he's going to clear the field
almost certainly
there was an iowa caucus poll that was
just taken
this was just obtained by breitbart
the survey from pollster rick shafton's
neighborhood research and media shows
that trump right now is polling at
56 percent
significantly more than half the voters
in the iowa caucus poll
are on trump's side
okay
you know do you know who the number two
was the number two is ron desantis do
you know what his number was
12.3 percent
12.3
trump is beating
desantis the number two guy by more than
40 percentage points
after that you've got christy gnome 2.1
percent
after that you've got ted cruz pompeo
other people who are pompeo i forgot is
obviously looking to run
20.8 are undecided but it doesn't matter
how many people are undecided more than
half the voters are with trump so it's
it's not it's not as though well with
some good messaging and positioning
maybe ron desantis or somebody could no
i mean right now trump is just
dominating this field
and how did he do that one he's a kind
of singular political figure but two
he's persistent he just won't let up
the guy has been running for president
again ever since
the ballots came into georgia and
wisconsin at three o'clock in the
morning on election night 2020.
and it reminds you a lot of the gop
positioning right now is moot the
question that the republicans have to
answer is not do i like desantis moore
or cruz moore or christie gnome or
pompeo or whatever the the question
republicans have to answer is do we want
trump again or not
if you do done your campaign's ready to
go if you don't
you've got to find a way to communicate
that in such a way that trump doesn't
run because even if you don't want trump
if trump runs i think the the primary is
basically
over plus who cares who cares who gets
the republican nomination for president
who cares even who gets the democrat
nomination for president
we all know who's really running the
country come on
who who who is the most powerful
politician in the country and therefore
in the world
five letters preceded by one title
dr
fauci and our supreme leader dr fauci
has some good news for us or for some of
us
in his beneficence in his magnanimity dr
fauci is going to permit some of us
to celebrate thanksgiving and christmas
this year
if you get vaccinated and your family's
vaccinated
you can feel good about enjoying a
typical thanksgiving christmas with your
family and close friends
we unfortunately still have
a dynamics of infection in the community
of about 70 000 new cases per day
so when you go to indoor congregate
settings
go the extra mile
be safe wear a mask but when you're with
your family at home
goodness enjoy it with your parents your
children your grandparents there's no
reason not to do that
this will end bill we are not going to
be going through this
indefinitely how quickly we get to the
end
depends on us
how well we vaccinate how well we get
boosted and how well we do the kinds of
things to protect ourselves
thank you dr fauci thank you for telling
me that i am permitted to have
thanksgiving and christmas
with my close family and friends not you
know not with anybody because you can't
invite your co-workers all right you
can't have i'm not talking about a
12-person table but you know close
people
if you're vaccinated but what does it
mean to be well you ought to be
vaccinated and boosted
okay and you've got in the and at the
other occasions you need you do need to
wear your mask because this is going to
end don't worry dr fauci is promising
you this is going to end very soon
if you comply
if it depends on you okay you naughty
little americans if you don't if you
don't comply it's going to go on longer
it's going to maybe seem indefinite
it's going to end 15 days it's just 15
more days guys okay
but you've got to weigh the mask
now you've got to social distance now
you've got to take the vacs now you've
got to take the other vex then you've
got to take the booster then you're
getting just one more thing just one
more thing you sheep then you can go
back to normal you got to get another
booster again
speaking of the rona speaking of
coronavirus
because a lot of people don't want to
listen to fouchy and don't want to wear
the masks forever and don't want to
take the 17th booster shot and done even
now i fly on airlines constantly i'm
just i've been every few days i've been
on a flight for the past two months
especially i was on one i was on two
flights yesterday actually to to and
from los angeles and i'm noticing they
don't they don't really enforce the mask
thing anymore and i'm not sure if it's
because the airlines don't want to do it
or i think it's just because people
aren't going to do it and so the ruling
class
only has so much power if we all just
said no they would be helpless
right and so they do have to calibrate
their
rule
to what we're willing to tolerate
right that is that is why dr fauci
initially said i i don't know if you can
have christmas in thanksgiving and then
there was a big push back and he said oh
never mind never mind i never said that
what do you know you can have it just
get 17 more boosters get this get you
know and it's it's a bit of a
negotiation so because people are sick
of this nonsense the ruling class is
pulling out all the stops the
entertainment the media saturday night
live
they just they ran i i guess what's
supposed to be a comedy sketch
about a flap between big bird and ted
cruz
the the muppets and sesame street
insisting that everyone take a bunch of
vaccines ted cruz said make your own
medical decisions and don't listen to a
puppet bird and and joe rogan too was in
this just take a listen
tell me if you can identify the comedy
yeah
well that's right
i used the whole sphere factor and now
doctors fear me
can you help me joe oh sure thing big
bird you see i said carlos mencia down i
could take coven
here's some zinc
an ayahuasca
and some horse medicine
why would a bird take horse medicine i'm
a human and i took horse medicine
and i'm speaking of things that are
horse-like uh today's two sponsors are
the letters s and d as in i can s my own
d
what
was the joke
you were there was some laughing i mean
i wonder if it was laugh track or if it
was the actual studio audience or maybe
some combination
but even with that even with a studio
audience and potentially a laugh track
a bunch of those lines didn't even land
they didn't i don't even know what the
joke was
was the joke that
joe rogan took some kooky witch doctor
medicine for kovid that wouldn't work
joe rogan recovered from the coronavirus
in like five hours
is that the joke is that he took horse
medicine he didn't take horse medicine
though
is the joke that
joe rogan is some fringe lunatic but
dr fauci or you know dr fauci is now uh
viceroy and vicars you know and through
big bird and and other representatives
of the
ruling class that they are somehow
serious and respected and popular i
don't think they are i think joe rogan
is one of the most popular communicators
and broadcasters in the world
and dr fauci is the butt of everyone's
jokes
is is the is the joke that
the people who are questioning the
regime and questioning joe biden for
instance are fringe and weird and
radical and biden is really popular no
biden's approval rating is about as low
as it gets
what is it 37 38
what's the joke the joke would
be like what what comedy used to do is
speak truth to power right what comedy
used to do is juxtapose incongruous
things
and
and it would be funny and you would
laugh at that which is ridiculous but in
in this case what is ridiculous is not
the fringe clown it's not it's not the
joe rogan what's ridiculous is the
ruling class
and saturday night live far from being a
critic of the ruling class is part of it
and it's a it's an extension of it and
it's part of the propaganda outlet and
so it's just not
funny it's just not funny and snl has
been hit or miss for an extremely long
time
really hasn't been funny since norma
mcdonald left the show but it's had its
moments this is a real low point and
they're not going to figure it out
until
they break away from the ruling class
but unfortunately it's the kind of the
ruling class that's propping up these
old desiccated establishment
institutions like the establishment
media and like even saturday night live
speaking of tone deafness
donna brazile former head of the dnc was
just on george stephanopoulos's show
george stephanopoulos the former
communications director for bill clinton
and they were on abc and they're both
pretending to be journalists and donna
brazile was asked about
inflation
and this is a really tough issue it's
plaguing biden's approval numbers and
it's really hitting americans of all
classes of all races everywhere
and
to his credit stephanopoulos says what
are people supposed to do about
inflation donna brazile says you know
i don't clip some coupons
inflation has been going up for the last
three years i go to i go to safeway come
on i go look look you got it look you
you've got to be smart when you go out
and shop today okay whether you're
looking for jiffy cornbread which used
to be three for a dollar and it went up
to 87 cents or if you're buying gas and
if you buy it in the inner city it's
10 cents more than if you go out just to
f further out
well
that's the democratic slogan no we're
gonna raise your prices but be smart
about it could be a little bit less you
mentioned marijuana
you mentioned mary pat i'm just telling
you my experience of shopping you got to
be a smart shopper you got to be a smart
shopper look if you go into the inner
city gas is going to be 10 cents more
okay and if you go to california it's
going to be seven dollars a gallon so
you know just clip some coupons just be
a smart shopper this is
tone deaf
that that's the real problem for the snl
writers is that they're tone deaf and if
you want to write comedy if you want to
write music if you want to
create any cultural product you need to
be able to hear
the the tone of the people you need to
be here able to hear the tenor of the
conversation what's actually going on
but these guys are so stuck in their
echo chambers that donna brazil says oh
yeah okay pancake mix is 20 cents more
per box whatever what you poor people
can't afford that just be a smart
shopper come on just have when you have
whole foods deliver to your georgetown
penthouse just just order you know order
in bulk so that you can save a little
bit on on the quantity just be a smart
shopper
and chris christie
quite rightly says if democrats want to
run on that please do that is not going
to resound for the
american people really weak arguments
that they're making from the written
house case all the way to electoral
politics what they're hoping for is that
they have such a structural advantage
that it won't matter if their arguments
don't make any sense at all i'm michael
nolis the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show